[Musik]
es sind wieder corona entscheidungs tage
in deutschland am dienstag kommt die
sogenannte ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
zusammen gibt es dann ein lockdown für
nicht geimpfte warum schau die politiker
überhaupt noch so auf die inzidenz
obwohl die kaum noch etwas sagt und wann
bekommen wir endlich unsere freiheit
zurück über diese fragen möchte ich
diskutieren mit der ehemaligen fdp
justizministerin sabine
leutheuser-schnarrenberger mit dem chef
der kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung
andreas gassen und mit den
csu-generalsekretär markus blume schönen
guten abend an alle drei herr blume mit
ihnen möchten wir anfangen ich wurde
heute bei einem mittags besuch im
biergarten hier in berlin von meinen
freunden gefragt sag mal ihr müsst das
doch wissen wann ist endlich schluß band
gibt es unseren freiheitstag wie in
england
können sie da eine prognose wagen corona
das leider immer wieder gezeigt
herrnsheimer dass es mit den prognosen
sehr schwierig ist und wenn ich mir so
die jüngsten umfragen anschaue dann gibt
es einen werte relativ stabil ist die
deutschen wünschen sich vor allem eines
neben dem weg zur normalität vor allem
sicherheit und wir sind nach wie vor bei
krone nicht überm berg wir merken dass
die zahlen mit hoher dynamik wieder
steigen
klar ist aktuell die inzidenz werte sind
anders zu bewerten als noch vor drei
vier fünf monaten
aber es ist einfach zu früh entwarnung
zu geben und deswegen müssen wir alles
tun sicherzustellen dass deutschland
weiterhin gut durch die korona pandemie
kommt wenn sie die zahlen an sprechen
herr blume und sie haben ja gerade
selbst gesagt die inzidenz sollte nicht
mehr das einzige sein möchte ich ihnen
einmal zeigen wie die hospitalisierung
rate momentan ist und wenn wir uns das
genau anschauen dann sehen wir dass
dieser wert massiv gefallen ist wir
wissen dass am 4
august am ende dass es die gesamt
gemeldete betten lage freie betten und
corona prozent also die intensivbetten
auslastung aber am vierten august betrug
die hospitalisierung rate am ende knapp
100 rechtfertige das erneut maßnahmen
beziehungsweise rechtfertigt das dass
sie uns immer noch nicht sagen wollen
wann diese maßnahmen enden auch dänemark
hat gesagt ab erster oktober alles
wieder offen keine maßnahmen mehr
naja wir sehen gerade bei diesem 2 diese
gerade gezeigt haben wir uns habe zum
ersten mal seit monaten dass diese kurve
wieder nach oben geht zwar nur ganz
leicht aber es macht sie so reden die
bürger für die emissions- das niveau ja
anschauen das ist ja das ist ja immer
viel viel geringer bei ihnen die
intensivbetten auslastung ist ein
absoluter spätindikator das heißt wenn
es beginnt dort zu drehen
das heißt wenn wieder mehr menschen
hospitalisiert werden dann ist es mit
ganz großem zeitlichem nachlauf zum
aktuellen infektionsgeschehen und die
uns erzählen dass in diese zahlen das
rechtfertigen der wonsheimer ich weiß
jetzt nicht worauf sie hinauswollen also
es ist heute nicht der tag um zu sagen
das koma beendet ist
schauen sie sich um in der welt wir
sehen dass die delta variante
hochansteckend ist zum glück sind wir in
deutschland nach wie vor relativ
niedrigen niveau
aber die dynamik die wir aktuell sehen
ist viel höher als im vergangenen jahr
und ich sage das alles heute nicht um
neue schreckensszenarien zu verbreiten
das gegenteil ist der fall
aber es ist eben auch zu früheren jetzt
komplett entwarnung zu geben und ich
habe einfach den vorsichtigen verdacht
dass all diejenigen die freiheits tage
und anderes aus rufen dann relativ
schnell wieder ihre fahnen einrollen
müssen wir haben gesehen in den
niederlanden der premier hat sich dort
entschuldigt bei seiner bevölkerung dass
er so fahrlässig unterwegs war wir sehen
auch das sind england die zahl wir sehen
auch und herr blume wir sehen auch dass
in england die zahlen eben nach dem
freiheitstag runtergegangen sind das
gehört zu weit auch dazu verleite
schnarrenberger wenn sie das hören was
der csu-generalsekretär nochmal die
neuen in praxi und noch eines raumes
britannien ich habe jetzt eine frage an
frau leutheuser-schnarrenberger wie
nehmen sie das wahr wenn herr blume über
corona spricht da hat man doch das
gefühl man will uns irgendwie noch ein
bisschen länger einsperren oder haben
sie hoffnung dass irgendwann der
freiheitstag kommt
also ich glaube man muss einfach jetzt
mal sehr nüchtern sagen die situation
ist anders als wir sie im letzten herbst
erlebt haben weil durch die impfquote
auch wenn sie noch nicht so hoch ist wie
wir sie haben wollen
doch eine ganz andere gefahr und zwar
eine ganz geringe gefahr für das
gesundheitswesen da ist und wenn wir mal
einen blick ins gesetz werfen
dann heißt es ja im
infektionsschutzgesetz es muss eine
ernsthafte gefahr für das
gesundheitswesen vorliegen um die
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite festzustellen das sehe ich im
moment nicht wir haben gott sei dank
eine änderung der situation und ich
finde
lasst es uns doch ehrgeizig sein lasst
es uns doch anstreben dass wir auf alle
fälle weg aus der ausnahme situation
kommen dass es eben keine grundlage in
vielen bereichen mehr für freiheits
beschränkende maßnahmen gibt ob es nun
ein tag ist aber ich finde das ziel muss
sein wir müssen raus aus einer
ausnahmesituation und wann könnte den
freiheitstag sein mietauto
schnarrenberger man könnte da seien hier
in deutschland aus ihrer sicht also dato
ist natürlich schwierig zu sagen ganz
klar
man sollte sich ehrgeizige ziele setzen
es ist normal oktober genannt worden
aber ich finde wenn man das sind sie für
oktober wird vor allem autoren dahin
wollen also während der optimale
situation aber ich möchte hier nicht mit
irgendwelchen daten also jetzt nur so
hantieren weil das wieder die debatte so
verkürzt die wir doch einfach gut iga
führen sollten nicht dahin wie können
wir den lockdown weiter gestalten
sondern wie kommen wir raus aus dem
lokal vergessen wir haben gerade schon
einige zahlen gesehen werden die aus
italiens rate gesehen wir haben von der
blume gehört dass man nicht mehr nur auf
die inzidenz schauen soll aber jetzt
gingen die zahlen der wieder hoch laut
eben der csu die ja ganz entscheidend
auf der seite derjenigen stehen die
sagen wir müssen vorsichtig sein
wie ist ihre sicht auf die dinge was
haben sie von den ärzten aus dem ganzen
land was denkt man momentan über die
politik die
hier in berlin aber auch in den ländern
gemacht wird na ja gut da gibt es könnte
man sich jetzt stundenlang daran
abarbeiten was was versäumt wurde über
monate und jahre nehmen wir nur die
schulen aber das beste ist die zeit
heute zu kurz also ich glaube man muss
das ist das was politik glaube ich mal
anerkennen muss dieses ganze was wir in
den letzten alter erleben haben fußt ja
ein bisschen auf dem auf dem prinzip der
kontrollieren also man glaubt ja
politisch durch maßnahmen wie ruß
ansteckungen relevant beeinflussen zu
können das funktioniert und
erfreulicherweise nicht das zeigen auch
alle mittlerweile aufgesetzten studie
man hat also versucht ja immer
korrelationen daraus zu finden wir
machen lockt donnerstag in runter das
hat sich alles nicht bewahrheitet und
das ist weltweit überall das gleiche
phänomen was wirklich funktioniert sind
tatsächlich impfungen sich funktionieren
nicht
um ansteckungen zu verhindern sie
funktionieren auch nicht um ihn zieht es
noch nur zunächst das festhalten an die
inzidenz wirklich kontraproduktiv um
kein anderes wort zu benutzen sondern
wir erleben ein ganz verändert
desinfektions und krankheitsgeschehen
und darauf kommt es an
corona ist nicht im oktober weg wie im
november ich bezweifle dass ich noch
erlebe das corona verschwindet und ich
fühle mich noch ganz rüstig aber wir
werden uns mit diesem virus ähnliche mit
anderen viren arrangieren müssen das
wird perspektivisch auch weiterhin kein
problem mehr sein wir werden irgendwann
durchseuchung haben sei es entweder die
menschen sind geimpft oder sie haben es
halt bekommen
das scheint sich bei der infektiosität
dieses virus so herauszukristallisieren
jetzt kommt es darauf an über welchen
zeitraum und das ist auch die frage
freiheitstag im grundsatz ja natürlich
nicht bedingungslos und nicht mit einem
datum das wäre glaube ich auch nichts
hier führen also wenn jetzt sagen wir
einigen uns auf den ersten 10 und aus
welchen gründen auch immer haben wir
plötzlich tatsächlich immenses
infektionsgeschehen mit krankenhaus sehr
gut aber das würde ich ja jeder
verstehen erlassen wenn es dann
tatsächlich dieses erhöhte
infektionsgeschehen und auch eine
hospitalisierung rate gibt aber ich
meine wenn die menschen jetzt diese
zahlen sehen und dann hören dass die
politiker wieder warnen und mahnen um
gottes willen die institute ist jetzt
bei ein bisschen über 20 und da fragt
man sich doch wann soll das irgendwann
noch mal aufhören ja das muss aufhören
und wir haben sie denn sonst können
in der welt hat ich glaube wenn wir die
inzidenz unserer nachbarländer händen
dann werden wir wenn wir im komplett
lockdown möglicherweise fehlt der
aktuellen bundesregierung neun
verbleibenden sechs wochen die sich noch
im amt ist auch die politische kraft
noch etwas zu ändern
wir haben ja einen vorschlag gemacht den
ich auch unverändert aufrechterhalten
würde im grundsatz muss man sagen wenn
jeder ein angebot bekommen hat also ein
realistisches einzel haltendes dann
glaube ich müsste man zumindest
sukzessive die maßnahmen zurückfahren
dann muss der kollektiv schutz der ja
auch nur begrenzt funktioniert einem
individual schutz weichen was nicht
heißt dass wir völlig leichtsinnig
werden und es mag durchaus gute gründe
geben dass man ihn beispielsweise einem
korb aus auch so noch eine maske trägt
aber letztlich ist das eine freie eine
freie entscheidung meine ich das
krankheitsgeschehen ist aktuell extrem
niedrig das muss man sagen und um das
auch mal deutlich zu sagen weil das wird
ja immer diese diese mär vom überlastung
des gesundheitssystems ist das war die
überlasteten wir waren noch nie in der
nähe nicht gar nicht ist die kollegin
wegen auf intensivstationen haben viel
zu tun gehabt und das war auch nicht
schön
das machen die sehr professionell
deshalb sind versäumnisse der
vergangenheit die personalmangel zu tage
getreten aber wir waren nie auch nur in
der nähe eines versagens des
gesundheitswesens wer das behauptet hat
eine sehr eigene interpretation der
zahlen
herr blume da muss ich direkt man sie
anschließen denn sie gehörten zu
denjenigen beziehungsweise ihre partei
die immer wieder vor einer überlastung
der intensivstation gewarnt hat warum
na ja also ich muss ehrlich sagen ich
finde manche these die jetzt hier von
herrn dr gassen verbreitet wurde recht
abenteuerlich auch im rückblick es ist
doch völlig klar und das ist ja auch
festgestellt worden vom rk ii und von
anderen institutionen dass es
deutschland gelungen ist zehntausende
von leben zu schützen und zwar aufgrund
der tatsache dass wunderblume sie
glauben dass sie sich besser auskennen
der chef der kassenärztlichen
bundesvereinigung wenn sie sagen das ist
abenteuerlich also das ist ja fast ein
bisschen arrogant gegenüber ja also ich
sehe das weiß nicht auf welche daten
grundlage er sich alleine ein land ein
amt alleine gibt noch keine weisheit und
das gilt für jeden fall meine ausbildung
zu leicht wenn man mediziner
man sich vielleicht ein bisschen der
sache ja manchmal darüber lesen
ich will nicht dass das was er und
andere in den letzten wochen
veröffentlicht haben und jetzt zu
behaupten jegliche politische maßnahmen
wie irgendwo ergriffen hätten er würde
in keiner weise wirken ist doch eine
wirklich abenteuerliche behauptung dass
in vergessen so luthe goldstandard ist
das ist doch selbstverständlich dass
auch das was wir das was wir dringend
voranbringen müssen aber solange wir
keine impfmöglichkeit hatten zu
behaupten jegliche maßnahmen der politik
wäre völlig zweckfrei gewesen es ist
einfach falsch und das nämlich eines
noch sagen und das ist sehr politisch
ich halte es für falsch wenn wir wenn
der deutsche bund aber den vorwurf muss
ich jetzt einmal klären der blume dann
kommen wir zu ihnen zurück herr gassen
also zu ihren thesen herr blume gesagt
das ist falsch das abenteuerlich was ich
sagen ja ich habe ja nein das ist dann
muss der blumen einfach mal die die
quellen zu lesen dass agiert klar gesagt
dass das impfen zehntausende tote
gerettet hat und nicht sie auf maßnahmen
kapriziert das wäre auch eine verstiegen
eine wahrnehmung selbst die uni münchen
hat ja sehr schöne arbeit zu lockdown
effektivität mann ich habe ich gesagt
jede maßnahme nichts geholfen hat ich
habe nur gesagt es muss nach anderthalb
jahre eine lernkurve geben und ich war
unter anderem einer der die gerade die
maßnahme bei der ersten welle
unterstützt haben
aber man muss ja nach zwei jahren
irgendwann mal feststellen es kann nicht
so weiter gehen und wenn ich zum
beispiel höre das jetzt weil ich wir
müssen jetzt ein plan für die
schuleröffnung haben finde ich dass
eltern mit vielen kindern ohne
zumutungen aber nochmal haben gesagt ja
es gibt ihn noch keine weisheit stimmt
es das ist sicherlich das gilt für alle
ämter und das erleben wir ja jeden tag
in der öffentlichen diskussion dass das
der fall ist
es gilt der alte spruch manchmal sieht
akku ist es aber unabhängig davon ist es
ja nicht so dass ich das kraft eigener
wasser so bei dir warum mehr gebe
sondern sie wissen wir haben ein
institut mit vielen pharmakologen
epidemiologen die uns natürlich die
studien sehr präzise auswerten und sind
in der intensiven diskussion ich kann an
der stelle sagen
an dem punkt natürlich wie karl
lauterbach endverbraucher von studien
wir machen die er alle beide nicht
selber aber ich kann sie lesen und das
ist müssen sie mir zugestehen
das tue ich halt mit dem mit
medizinischen sachverstand und den
werden wir aller voraussicht nach nicht
absprechen können sich im zweifel auch
mit leben aber man muss glaube ich
einfach anerkennen es geht ja gar nicht
darum dass man jetzt den besserwisser
retrospektiv man aber wir wissen ja mal
man in die zukunft schauen und wenn ich
natürlich immer wieder die gleiche
reaktion auf unterschiedliche
rahmenbedingungen dann muss ich die
zumindest hinterfragen und ich glaube so
weit sind wir doch eher blume dass die
einigkeit mittlerweile überall besteht
dass es nicht so weitergehen kann wie
vor zeugen und die inzidenz offene
schlesier dass nur ein hinweis kann ich
echt ins ident ist die biologen würden
die anders definieren kein parameter ist
sie sprechen es an die inzidenz da hat
sich der bundesgesundheitsminister jens
spahn geäußert was aus seiner sicht in
der kommenden zeit entscheidend ist also
stand heute wenn sie einfach schauen wir
haben 75 prozent der über 60 jährigen
sind vollständig geimpft drei viel
einfiel nicht wenn sie die maßzahl
nehmen können so sagen 200 ist das neue
50 vierfache 200 ist das neue 50er blume
was bedeutet das also zunächst mal habe
ich jetzt beim herrn dr gassen
annäherung festgestellte ich würde das
teilen was er jetzt im zweiten lauf
gesagt hat dass uns jetzt nach
anderthalb jahren andere dinge einfallen
müssen ist doch ganz klar
deutschland kann nicht wieder einfach in
den lotter und für alle gehen sondern
wir müssen hier differenzieren
es stehen uns ja jetzt zum glück auch
andere dinge zur verfügung insofern
glaube ich gibt es ja große
gemeinsamkeit das zweite was ich sagen
will ist ich halte es für notwendig dass
der deutsche bundestag das fortbestehen
der epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite beschließt aus einem ganz
einfachen grund wir würden sonst völlig
ungeschützt und zwar auch was den
gesamten maßnahmenkatalog angeht in den
herbst gehen
deswegen ist es aus meiner sicht
dringend notwendig dass dieses
fortbestehen der pandemischen lage
beschlossen wird weil uns sonst
sämtliche instrumente aus der hand
genommen werden und das dritte ist wir
müssen uns vor allem darüber gedanken
machen wie wir die rechte und die
freiheit der geimpften und genießen
schützen können
es kann nicht sein dass diejenigen die
mit dem
annahme des angebots einen ganz
wichtigen solidarischen beitrag für alle
geleistet haben aber zuvor dass
natürlich auch für sich selbst
dass die am ende dann genauso behandelt
werden wie diejenigen die aus welchen
gründen auch immer sagen wir lassen uns
nicht impfen nicht gesagt der blumen und
keine einzige war an der antwort auf
meine frage die waren nämlich was
bedeutet incidents 200 ist die neue 50
das bedeutet dass eine inzidenz wert
wenn wir den im herbst erreichen sollten
von 200 nicht die 200 von früher ist
sondern wie ein spannendes formuliert
hat eben eine ganz andere qualität hat
es müssen andere dinge dazu kommen
alexander dobrindt hat heute den
fortschritt als weiteren indikator
herangeführt und natürlich ist auch die
intensivbetten auslastung ein weiterer
indikator
wir brauchen am ende ein ampelsystem ein
ampelsystem was der bevölkerung auf
einfache art und weise in deutschland
signalisiert was geht und was nicht geht
und deswegen ist es notwendig dass die
länder sich darüber verständigen heißt
das infektionsschutzgesetz muss
überarbeitet werden weil da ist zum
beispiel ab 100 gibt's dann gibt es dann
in gewisse gibt es die ausgangssperre
gibt's die notbremse und viele dinge die
dort drin stehen
ich halte das für zwingend notwendig
weil wir jetzt natürlich in einer ganz
anderen situation sind als vor einem
halben jahr
selbstverständlich wie sollte das dann
überarbeitet werden vorleute
schnarrenberger wenn sie die debatte
hören und wie sehen sie das wenn er
sparen sagt 200 ist die 950 weil gefüllt
kann man doch sagen am ende ist die
inzidenz auch wenn sie weit über 200 ist
und wir wissen dass so viele menschen im
alltag geimpft sind und wenn wir wissen
dass kinder und jugendliche rein
statistisch
kein hohes todesrisiko haben oder keine
hospitalisierung risiko haben dann kann
das doch viel höher liegen noch oder
also ich denke auch die 200 ja nicht ein
absoluter wert sein um zu sagen daran
rechtfertigen gehe dann wieder den
lockdown die zeiten müssen vorbei sein
und das infektionsschutzgesetz muss
natürlich und zwar am besten jetzt bevor
dann im herbst wieder in allen
bundesländern die ferien zu ende sehen
wir haben ja schon die ersten muss
geändert werden einmal halte ich es
nicht für nach dem jetzigen gesetz für
möglich einfach die epidemische lage
weiter festzustellen weil die ernsthafte
gefahr für die öffentliche
gesundheitsversorgung nicht festgestellt
werden kann
das hat ja gerade die kassen auch in
seinen worten sehr deutlich gemacht also
kann man nicht einfach sagen wir machen
so weiter wie bisher
wir brauchen dann im
infektionsschutzgesetz änderungen dass
man gewisse maßnahmen an mehrere
kriterien knüpft und zwar nicht dass es
immer nur gesagt wird die inzidenz sei
ja nicht alles sondern dass es
tatsächlich auch verbindlich ist
impfquote hospitalisierung skate und
nennwert wie sich die infektionen
entwickeln aber eingebettet herr blume
sprach von einer ampel so etwas was
schon aus verschiedenen ländern immer
wieder vorgeschlagen wird das gehört in
infektionsschutzgesetz hinein aber es
braucht wirklich eine überarbeitung das
geht nicht in einer einzigen sitzung mal
im bundestag und das erwarte ich dass
das im sommer geleistet wird damit wir
aus diesem lockdown rauskommen
denn natürlich können wir für geimpfte
und genesene keine weiteren
beschränkungen der freiheitsrechte
rechtfertigen auch keine massen
höchstgebot auch keine masken mehr
bild reuters numbers also gerade auf
eine maske für für geimpfte im raum
brauche ich auch keine maske wenn die
keine gefahr da sind brauch ich für
geimpfte und genesene keine maske im
raum
er appelliere ich an die
verantwortung der bürger und die ist
gewachsen in den letzten monaten
das sehen wir doch das teilweise
selbstverständlich eine maske aufgesetzt
wird draußen sowie in asiatischen
ländern schon bei smog und bei anderen
gefahren der fall ist aber ich glaube
wir haben eine stärkere
eigenverantwortung und wir müssen alles
tun damit wir die die bisher nicht
geimpft sind und das sind ja noch ab 18
18 millionen menschen darunter natürlich
noch sehr viele mehr
da müssen wir mit dem impfstoff zu den
menschen damit wir diesen wettlauf
gewinnen und mit anhören impfquote dann
natürlich auch weg von den
beschränkungen ist somit kommen wir
gleich noch vergessen aber das ist eine
spannende frage also was ist dann für
geimpfte und genesene am ende möglich
sind sie auch der auffassung dass da die
masten pflicht fallen sollte also
grundsätzlich habe sie gesagt ich bin
der meinung dass das ab einem gewissen
punkt wir wissen impfung ist im
wesentlichen der beste individual-
schluss das heißt bin ich geimpft wenn
ich nahezu 100 prozent geschützt vor
schweren verlauf und tod dann muss ich
für mich selber entscheiden ob ich in
gewissen situationen maske tragen weil
ich gleich ängstlich bin oder weil ich
vielleicht doch mal und sagen gerade
erkältet bin ich würde die masken
pflicht tatsächlich einem individuellen
entscheidungen swords und über antworten
um noch mal auf die 200 zu kommen ich
glaube jetzt spart die diese diesen
ausdruck nicht gewählt weil er ist ein
star 200 fest das ist so ein bisschen
wie 60 ist die neue 40 sie kennen das
alle
ich finde den vorschuss von einem
dokument zumindest in die richtige
richtung gehen aber lassen sie mich
gleich etwas wasser in den wein gießen
so griffig eine ampel ist und ich kann
verstehen dass politiker gerne eine
ampel haben weil es auch gut
vermittelbar ist
die ist ein grünes geld aber wir
brauchen dann mehr parameter um die
farben der ampel zu bestimmen ich fand
beispielsweise den vorstoß der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft sehr gut
das ist etwas kompliziert oder wirkt
kompliziert aber sie brauchen nämlich
nur eine impfquote sie müssen auch
wissen wie ist regional geimpft das kann
ja sehr unterscheidet ist die alters
zusammen
wer wird krank sind es 200 raver mit
anfang zwanzig oder habe ich 50
hochbetagte das kann man aber machen das
ist nicht so schwierig wie es klingen
ist letztlich rocket science die
gesundheitsämter sollten diese daten
haben und das ermöglicht dann
tatsächlich den entscheidungsträgern vor
ich kann ja verstehen dass die was in
der hand haben wollen wo man in
irgendeiner form eben als nicht geologe
oder nicht ewig theologe trotzdem
politisch verantwortet entscheiden kann
das muss man dann in eine gewisse in
einem logarithmisch gießen und dann ist
es vielleicht mehr als drei parameter
aber damit kommen wir weiter und bei der
und das ist das betrifft dann auch die
masken pflicht geschichte ich glaube man
muss sich doch damit unter sind wir von
einem jahr massiv kritik eingesteckt
dass wir gesagt haben zusammen mit
hendrik steg und jonas schmidt chanasit
das virus kann man salopp formuliert ist
gekommen um zu bleiben und jetzt stellt
jeder fest ja stimmt wirklich
wir sehen wie desaströser zero kobe
thema australien jetzt im sektor militär
auf den straßen und einer impfquote von
unter 10% aussieht also impfen ist gut
impfen ist richtig da müssen wir ran
ich bin ein bisschen skeptisch was das
impfen insbesondere sehr jungen angeht
wir haben für neun millionen unter 12
jährige ohnehin weltweit kein impfstoff
die im kammer also schon mal rausnehmen
aus der gleich und gott sei dank werden
die nicht krank aber auch die zwölf- bis
17-jährige ist es gut dass es eine
infektion gibt aber ich glaube wir
müssen ganz deutlich dafür sorgen dass
das impfen dieser gruppe die das mit
ihren eltern ideal aber es entscheiden
das ist aber im 12 anders als beim
17-jährigen dass wir das in einem
setting machen wo diese entscheidung
unbeeinflusst stattfinden ich
unterstelle allen dass das so gemeint
ist aber ich befürchte wenn wir
impfungen in einer in einem setting
sport wir müssen noch mal kurz zum
impfen kommen wir gleich noch meine
frage sozusagen war in richtung des
gesetzes bzw
der masten also was erwarten sie jetzt
was auch bei der mpk passieren sollte
beziehungsweise was im herbst hier in
deutschland passiert also ich würde mir
wünschen dass man tatsächlich nicht
einen freedom day sondern einen
schwierigen bedingungen deklinieren und
dann auch wirklich sagt ab da ist es ein
gefahren wurde und ich würde
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass das
kommt ich glaube dass wir wahrscheinlich
so ein bisschen für die galerie so was
wie eine maske flächen in öffentlichen
räumen behalten werden
aber unverändert der meinung dass
geimpfte eigentlich so letztlich auch
jeder für sich selbst entscheiden kann
will hat eine maske tragen ja oder nein
aber ich würde meinen wenn ich die
diskussion so richtig waren glaube ich
da fehlt ein bisschen der politische mut
diese eigenverantwortung der bürger da
bin ich war forderte schnarrenberger die
leute sind mittlerweile anderthalb zwei
jahren sehr sensibilisiert die sind auch
fast über informiert manchmal kann es ja
schon nicht mehr hören ich glaube da
wird jeder für sich selber entscheiden
trage ich eine maske trage ich keine ich
denke das kann man den menschen über das
und ich muss sagen wenn ich menschen auf
dem fahrrad im wald mit einer maske sehe
dann denke ich wie vor unsicher sind
diese leute dann ist mittlerweile auch
die zeit gekommen wo wir den menschen
wieder mal ein bisschen geld machen und
angst in einem vernünftigen rahmen der
blume sind sie schuld daran dass die
menschen im wald mit maske fahrradfahren
nein sondern die menschen sind im
zweifelsfall ich habe das vorher
ausgeführt wollen auf der seite der
vorsicht stehen und da muss am ende
jeder für sich selbst entscheiden
welches maß er dafür richtig hält es ist
ja auch so dass der über sie gehen wir
an vorbehalte sind zb gebracht mitmachen
ist das präsent ist auf der zugspitze
mit einer maske weit und breit keine
menschen zu sehen
das ist dann ja auch eine
vorbildfunktion wo man sagt menschen
überall gefährlich ihr müsst überall
maske tragen
nein das macht doch jeder für sich
selbst entscheiden aber da irgendwo die
maske ist in haft ist im öffentlichen
raum in verkehrsmitteln usw
da ist hier nach wie vor das denkbar
mildeste und gleichzeitig auch ein sehr
effektives mittel und deswegen sehe ich
da im moment keine möglichkeit davon
abzurücken
ich bin zwar auch wünschen im zuge von
normalität signal alle geimpft sind oder
anders geschützt sind der blumen die man
sich die ansichten können es geht aber
am ende gleich ihr uns aber es geht
dabei am ende ja auch um die frage der
nachvollziehbarkeit und es kann
natürlich nicht sein dass dann kollektiv
die maske abgelegt wird und überhaupt
nicht mehr nachvollziehbar ist sind dann
nur geimpft und genießen dabei nicht
geschützt sind
das warenhaus in der eigenen
verantwortung zurück und sagen moment am
ende ist jeder für sein eigenes leben
verantwortlich wenn ich hier aus dem
springer aus rausgehe und nicht auf die
straße 8 und überfahren werde dann ist
es auch meine schuld also ganz ehrlich
heraus haben wir wollen es auch das wort
davon gefallen dass wir gerade im
lockdown werden von der frau leutheusser
schnarrenberger ganz ehrlich ich bin im
moment viel in bayern unterwegs bin im
biergarten
ich sehe dort verdammt die normalität
und lebensfreude ist jetzt nicht so dass
die menschen irgendwo eingesperrt
während es wird auch dort keine maske
getragen also es ist ja ganz viel
möglich und trotzdem glaube ich es ist
ein akt von ehrlichkeit der bevölkerung
zu sagen solange wir was das impfen und
andere dinge noch nicht komplett über
werk sind ist es notwendig dass die aha
regeln weiter beachtet werden es war
auch an den bereichen wo sonst kein
anderer schutz möglich ist durch den
winter hinein für uns noch ein also ganz
früher ganz wichtiges ganz wichtige
grundregeln sind aber das fragen sich
die menschen blumen bis wann wollen sie
auch wenn es aus ihrer sicht sozusagen
kleine dinge sind den menschen noch
vorschreiben bis wann wollen sie das
aufrechterhalten
ich glaube dass die achtsamkeit durch
den herbst und winter noch mal notwendig
sein wird
der unterschied zwischen 8 und
vorschriften
ja es ist das denkbar mildeste mittel
und wir sind noch nicht in einem zustand
dass man jetzt alle regeln fallen lassen
kann das ist doch ganz klar wir wissen
nicht welche neuen mutationen kommen und
am ende bin ich mir sicher ist die
bevölkerung in der lage sich dann auch
darauf einzustellen wenn die gefährdung
höhe ist dann wird man mehr schutz
brauchen und wenn wir schneller über den
berg sind dann kommen wir auch schneller
zur normalität und dann sagen sie uns
noch schneller blume bevor wir auf das
impfschema kommen dass er tatsächlich
das allerwichtigste ist auch in diesen
wochen und den nächsten monaten aber
viele menschen bewegt was wird da jetzt
am dienstag wieder beschlossen wie lange
wird die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
gehen und was haben sie dies wollen wir
uns vor
sie müssen wir unsere prognosen die
zukunft betreffen sind immer sehr
unsicher und bei den ministerpräsidenten
konferenzen geht das insbesondere ich
hoffe dass es möglich ist im kreis der
länder sich zu verständigen auf den
weiteren fahrplan ist es vorhergesagt
wurden völlig zu recht
in vielen ländern beginnt der
schulbetrieb relativ bald die ferien
enden und das ist dann glaube ich schon
gut und wichtig und zwar unabhängig von
jedem wahlkampf dass man sich gemeinsam
auf das weitere regelwerk verständigt
dass man definiert was sind die neuen
indikatoren ab was soll ab wann greifen
um eben zu zeigen dass man auch gelernt
hat aus der vergangenheit und
gleichzeitig aber auch gewillt ist das
heft des handelns weiter in der hand zu
behalten
also was ist mit den neuen indikatoren
schaffen sie das noch bis zum ende der
legislaturperiode da ein neues gesetz zu
schaffen
ich glaube ist es notwendig sich darüber
zu verständigen um das gelingen wird das
werden wir sehen da ist der erste
wichtige schritt jetzt die gemeinsame
bestandsaufnahme in dieser kommenden
aber wie sollte die aus ihrer sicht aus
csu sicht aussehen also wie könnte
dieses gesetz verändert werden also wir
können es heute hier bei bild live ich
sehe ihre ambitionen aber wir können
jetzt hier nicht gesetzgebungsarbeit
leisten
da muss zunächst mal gemeinsam ins grund
bewusstsein hergestellt werden wo stehen
wir was haben wir erreicht und ich
glaube das wichtigste thema aber das
hier heute abend auch noch reden wollen
ist tatsächlich die frage wie bringen
wir endlich die impfbereitschaft in
deutschland noch weiter denn innen ist
der absolute goldstandard bei der
bekämpfung von kooaba aber können sie
versprechen dass der dass die notbremse
in die nächsten wochen nicht mehr ab 100
gilt weil das wäre absurd
das ist sicherlich ein punkt über die
man dort reden muss und nochmal sie
persönlich habe er sich eine meinung
haben ich verstehe dass wir sagt er
jetzt herausfinden wollen aber meine
frage ist was ist mit diesem gesetz was
ist mit der notbremse ab wann gilt die
weil die ist jetzt zwingend gesetzlich
also ja es gibt gute gründe zu sagen ich
brauche eine andere grenze und wir haben
ja gerade auch gemeinsam miteinander
festgehalten dass andere indikatoren
eine rolle spielen und das kann nicht
die inzidenz alleine sein und es kann
auch nicht die 100 maßgeblich sein und
ich bin da sehr zuversichtlich dass es
gelingen wird
dann auch zu einem neuen indikatoren zu
kommen und die oder verabschiedeten am
ende die nächste regierung das dann erst
und wir sitzen dann im lock down oder
haben wieder eine notbremse oder
ausgangssperre
es geht nicht an dass nach dem bergsee
dass der deutsche bundestag ich sehe
dass der deutsche bundestag immer in der
lage war sich in dieser pandemie
zusammenzuraufen und auch die länder
immer zu lösungen gekommen sind wir
glücklicherweise anders als andere
länder sind wir in ihnen irgendwas
reingestolpert manchmal war es ein
bisschen knapp aber am ende ist es immer
gelungen und diese zuversicht die habe
ich auch jetzt wahlkampf hin oder her
von leutheusser schnarrenberger wie
empfinden sie das ja also ich finde es
muss nicht ganz klare botschaft aber von
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
ausgehen
konkrete punkte für die änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes ein fahrplan
wie man sich das vorstellt in der
bundestag muss das beraten der muss
einberufen werden die müssen sich darauf
einstellen können neue kriterien herr
gassen hat ja mehrere genannt auf der
grundlage evidenzbasiert als kriterien
im gesetz festgeschrieben weg von dieser
inzidenz keine verlängerung der
epidemischen lage weg von der
verordnungsermächtigung an den
gesundheitsminister hin dann zu
überbrückungs regelungen im
infektionsschutzgesetz abhängig dann von
einer entwicklung die darauf
ausgerichtet ist nicht dass wir jetzt in
locktow sind wieder in den lock down zu
kommen man darf nicht wieder in dieselbe
situation kommen in der wir waren und
das muss die klare botschaft mit
gesetzesauftrag von der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz sein
der dumme ist die csu für eine
sondersitzung im bundestag bereit
wir unterstützen alles was notwendig ist
aber ich will noch mal ganz deutlich
sagen was an die konkrete es wichtig ist
dass wir dass wir uns darüber
verständigen dass wir die pandemische
die epidemische lage verlängern
denn ansonsten würde der ganze
instrumentenkoffer der politik aus der
hand genommen insbesondere in einer zeit
dann beispielsweise wenn der deutsche
bundestag neu gewählt wird
ich halte das für zwingend notwendig
deutschland darf nicht wehrlos und
schutzlosen den herbst gehen sind wir
nicht herr blume erstens wenn sie das
gesetz ändern ist nicht schutzlos weil
die rechtssicherheit in einem neuen
gesetz schaffen und nicht auf die
verordnungen setzen
zweitens die länder sind sowieso
handlungsfähig weil die neben dem bund
sowieso auch entscheiden können also es
ist falsch zu sagen dass wenn jetzt die
epidemische lage nicht verlängert wird
sind wie schutzlos das ist es nicht aber
es muss die richtige entscheidung von
dem ministerpräsidenten von der
bundesregierung und dann sehr schnell
mit den beratungen am besten in zwei
drei wochen im bundestag getroffen
werden das muss der fahrplan seien
vergessen sie kennt sich selbst geben
ist immer gut und richtig gesetzt lasse
nämlich das noch sagen gesetzgebung ist
immer gut und richtig der deutsche
bundestag ist der zentrale ort
politischer entscheidungen
aber wir haben in der pandemie gesehen
dass viele dinge dann sehr schnell und
sehr kurzfristig entschieden werden
mussten und dass man das gesamte
verordnungs instrumentarium aus der hand
gibt das sehe ich definitiven allein
dieses ordnungs instrumentarium blume
das ist ja ein wort ungeheuer da habe
ich angst dass ich gleich wieder
irgendwo eingesperrt werden nehmen sie
diese worte her
ich wusste nicht dass der kav zehnter
[Gelächter]
ich wusste dass sie so schreckhaft zu
zahlen war das ist sogar von einem
solchen job also vor wonach politik habe
ich angst das gebe ich gerne zu
also die verarmte nur menschen die froh
waren dass in griechenland gelebt haben
ja ich bin auch froh in deutschland zu
leben und ich hoffe dass bald mehr
geimpft wird aber mit diesen
verordnungsermächtigungen die wir jetzt
ist ein sonderweg beschritten worden und
den brauchen wir nicht mehr und man
schlägt trotzdem der politik nicht die
möglichkeit des handelns aus der hand
aber wir machen es im gesetz und nicht
mit diesem weg der verordnungen
das haben die meisten
verfassungsjuristen um nur einen punkt
zu sagen auch sehr kritisiert und ich
glaube wir sollten jetzt wieder in die
andere form des handelns kommen einer
regierung nämlich durch gesetze und
nicht durch verordnung gerade mit blick
auf grund und freiheitsrechte
das ist nicht dem verordnungs
gesetzgeber überlassen das geht nicht
weiter vergessen was es ihr gefühl
glauben sie denn die politik hat so ein
bisschen auch freude daran gesetze und
ermächtigung weiterzuführen
weil man dann ja einfach einfacher
regieren kann der verdacht könnte
hinkommen ich hatte ja auch das
vergnügen an mehreren anhörungen
teilzunehmen und ich fand es schon
bemerkenswert dass sämtliche
verfassungsrichter die da waren
eigentlich die gesetzgebung in dieser
form hoch bedenklich fanden aber das ist
jetzt nicht meine baustelle ja kein
jurist als bürger muss ich sagen fühle
ich mich mit solchen gesetzen die
automatismen nach sich ziehen
grundsätzlich sehr unwohl und ich bin
auch nicht der meinung dass man die
epidemische lange nationaler tragweite
weiter fortschritte und hätte schon
lange werden sollen das ist meine
meinung muss sich dann und das ist
sicher unbequemer sachfragen stellen
konkrete lösungen zu entwickeln
ich glaube das ist auch zwar sehr bequem
zum gesetz zu machen aber wir sehen auch
wie schnell wir da sozusagen gefangen in
einer solchen nicht mehr zeitgemäßen
eine solche nicht mehr zeitgemäßen
regelwerks werden und die zahlen die
einen zugrunde gelegt worden was an sich
schon skurril war dass man solche werte
im gesetz rein schreibt die keinerlei
keinerlei wissenschaftliche begründung
haben und das sagt ihnen auch jeder der
dabei war dass das letztlich einen
diskussionsergebnisse warum auf die
fünfte 35 waren wie auf einem
orientalischen basar wenn man das noch
sagen darf ohne politisch unkorrekt zu
werden aber das hat ja eine lange
tradition das handeln so ist diese
intelligenz jahr ausgehandelt worden das
ist ja nicht dass es dazu studien gelten
ab der jetzt nochmals oa dr
und wie gesagt ins ident ist es ja
ähnlich sondern es ist ja nur die zahl
der positiv getesteten menschen einer
zufälligen kollektivs
das zum abschluss zu dieser thematik
herr blume war das wieder offenbar sah
als sie da die inzidenz festgelegt haben
also ich sehe dieses wort an der stelle
es nicht angebracht an natürlich
versucht man sich irgendwo zu treffen
und politik besteht immer aus dem finden
von kompromissen
aber ich habe gerade die letzten
anderthalb jahre erlebt in dem alle
regierungen versucht haben sehr
evidenzbasiert voranzugehen und wie
immer wenn es auch in der wissenschaft
unterschiedliche haltungen und meinungen
gibt dann muss man sich halt irgendwo
bei einem punkt treffen und am ende ist
dann aber nicht entscheiden die
nachkommastelle und ob es dann 35 oder
50 sind die grobe richtung ist
entscheiden und eines möchte ich schon
festhalten
es war nicht deutschland was hier einen
absonderlichen sonderweg gegangen wäre
sondern im gegenteil wir haben es
geschafft durch sehr effektive
stringente maßnahmen und durch viel
disziplin in der bevölkerung heute auf
einem infektions niveau zu sein und dass
uns viele andere länder beneiden die
inzwischen wieder damit zu kämpfen haben
dass sich bei ihnen die infektionszahlen
auf ganz anderem niveau bewegen
ich möchte dominik alan damit in die
runde holen ein wird hier aus berlin der
die diskussion mit verfolgt hat und sich
große sorgen macht um sein geschäft
schönen guten abend herr galander wenn
sie das hören was hier besprochen wurde
was auch eine blume gesagt hat also eine
verlängerung der epidemischen lage
gesetze die weiter aufrechterhalten
wollen wir sorgen macht ihn das also ich
muss sagen die letzten anderthalb jahre
waren natürlich echt heftig am
schlimmsten bei all dem ist natürlich
für uns gastronomen die ja die nicht
planbarkeit also irgendwie in immer
kürzeren abständen gibt es immer neue
sachen die zu beachten sind und hört das
nervt jetzt mitunter jetzt gibt es
debatten darüber was am dienstag auch
passieren könnte nämlich die frage ob
eventuell nur noch geimpfte und genesene
in lokale in bars gehen können was wird
das für sie bedeuten
naja wenn man jetzt mal davon ausgeht
dass und ich glaube eine solche zahl
gehört zu haben weist aber nichts
genaues aber wenn ich jetzt davon
ausgehen dass 30 prozent unserer
zielgruppe beispielsweise ungeimpft ist
und noch nicht genesen ist
dann wäre das 30 prozent umsatzverlust
und das tut weh werden sie dann pleite
also da gebe es jetzt mehrere szenarien
1 wäre sicherlich zu überlegen bei 30
prozent umsatzverlust zuzusperren und zu
sagen okay das geht nicht mehr
also ich mein man könnte ja auch mal die
lufthansa fragen was die machen würden
wenn jeder dritte platz nicht mehr
besetzt werden dürfte aber die die
greift man nicht an sind ja mal wieder
und der nächste szenario wäre natürlich
dann zu sagen okay wir müssen den
umsatzverlust irgendwie ausgleichen
bedeutet die die noch übrig sind also
die geimpften und genießen die dann
unsere gäste sind dürfen 30 prozent mehr
zahlen
dann sind wir bei einem tonic von 20
euro mal gucken wie das gut geht
herzlichen dank an der blume sind sie
bereit dann für einen gin tonic 20 euro
auszugeben oder werden sie das abwenden
die diese debatte die ja in diesen tagen
geführt wird nämlich die frage ob nur
noch getesten nur noch geimpfte und
genießen und eben nicht mehr getestete
in restaurants können wie es da ihre
haltung
ja ich hoffe dass es da auch andere
bessere szenarien gibt es die dinge die
er gelandet gerade befürchtet hat und an
die wand gemalt hat im eines glaube ich
es ganz zentral
wir müssen alles daran setzen dass es in
deutschland keinen komplett lockdown
mehr gibt und deswegen sage ich ganz
deutlich gerade für geimpfte und
genießen es geht darum auch deren recht
und deren freiheit zu schützen
deswegen sage ich ganz deutlich es soll
keinen lockdown für diese gruppen geben
und entsprechend dann auch nicht für die
einrichtungen wo diese menschen hingehen
hingegen können von und wir werden
darüber reden müssen dass wir ab einem
bestimmten infektions niveau
möglicherweise zu solchen
einschränkungen komme
für menschen die eben
nicht geimpfte oder genesen sind sehen
sie das dann genauso wie ihr
kanzlerkandidat armin laschet der hat
sich heute geäußert in der bild am
sonntag ich will ihnen das einmal zeigen
die überschrift dort aus der bild am
sonntag wo er ganz klar gesagt hat dass
am ende getestete wie impfte behandelt
werden müssen herr blume sehen sie das
genauso wie ihr kanzlerkandidat
ja ich sehe das etwas differenzierter
jens spahn hat ja ähnlich argumentiert
wie ich das jetzt gerade gemacht habe
hat gesagt es kann ein punkt kommen an
dem wir die geimpften und die genesenen
in den blick nehmen müssen
und diejenigen die in anführungszeichen
nur getestet sind und wir wissen ja dass
ein test gerade die schnelltests auch
definitiv nicht das sicherheits das
zuverlässigkeits niveau haben was wir
eigentlich bräuchten
dass es dann dort einschränkungen geben
muss ich bin mir sicher in der weiteren
debatte wir müssen uns das noch mal
etwas differenzierter anschauen aber das
hole mir tanja bares ist aber tests
haben doch jetzt monatelang ausgereicht
und da hat man nicht sich den gedanken
gemacht ich sind ist das jetzt zu
unsicher wenn getesteter in ein
restaurant geht also wenn man nur
getestete nicht mehr in restaurants
lassen will weil man sie zwingen will
dass sie geimpft werden dann denke ich
wird das nicht zum erfolg führen da muss
man die impfkampagne anders machen aber
ich glaube darüber wird es schwierig und
wie will man vertreten dass tests
ausreichten monate lang und dafür viele
so der türöffner gewesen sind in
lockdown zeigen doch begrenzt kontakte
zu haben und sie dann komplett raus
nehmen
ich glaube das ist nicht nachvollziehbar
und nicht verständlich dass man alles
tut damit die die nicht total impfgegner
sind sich auch impfen lassen damit war
von dieser debatte möglichst weg kommen
da bin ich voll dabei und da muss man
auch sie noch sehr darauf konzentrieren
auch dass man vielleicht wenn alle immer
ins angebote bekommen sagt jetzt muss
man für den test was bezahlen bin ich
auch dabei das denke ich wäre ein
ansatzpunkt aber generell getestete
auszuschließen
das halte ich für problematisch da bin
ich dagegen ich sage ganz klar das
bessere ist der feind des guten und wir
haben jetzt etwas besseres als testen
nämlich impfen
und dann ist es doch klar das ist auch
eine abstufung geben muss und deswegen
gibt es ein klares pre in einer
situation von drastisch steigenden
neuinfektionen wenn die eintreten sollte
dass es dann auch zulässiges zu sich zu
überlegen wie kann ich die rechte von
geimpften und genesenen besser schützen
und mehr freiheit verwirklichen als alle
über einen kamm zu scheren
aber ich habe es noch nicht ganz
verstanden herr blume was genau sehen
sie dann anders als herr laschet also
sie wollen dann am ende diejenigen
schlechter stellen nein ich sage ganz
deutlich dass wir bei den geimpften und
genießen einfach ein höheres sicherheits
ein höheres schutzniveau haben und dass
es eine situation geben kann wo test
dann eben nur weil ich die situation
wurde sie bei jeder denn oder der
gastronomie
wann man ist so eine detailsuche
mehrzahl ich mag das jetzt nicht an der
zahl fest noch erwarten durch rechte
blume das wort die menschen wissen das
waren ich will wissen wieso wollen sie
uns das nicht sagen das verstehe ich
nicht
ich glaube dass es am ende doch nicht
das ist doch nicht von mir jetzt alleine
zu entscheiden haben sondern dass etwas
bei dem sich experten gedanken machen
müssen
ab welchem zustand und ab welcher lage
braucht ein höheres schutz nehmen dann
fragen wir mal hätte das heißt eben
nicht mehr auch sehr unser experte hier
können sie am meisten aus glaub ich
vergessen was ist da ihre überzeugung ja
das ist eine ganz schwierige frage und
im und muss man sagen fast alle haben
recht ein bisschen blumer natürlich
vollkommen recht wenn er sagt natürlich
sieht man der geimpft ist oder genesen
ist
er hat eine andere ich sage mal
sicherheits qualität was corona
ansteckung angetan jemand der nur
getestet es war die tests entwickelt es
keine pcs sind unsicherheit haben das
problem ist aber und das ist glaube ich
die entscheidende komponente unsicher
ist ja nur für die nicht geimpft werden
so nicht habe überhaupt keine fantasie
wie man in einem in einer situation die
man ja auch konstruieren könnte wo ihn
setzen steigen wir sagen so jetzt wird
es langsam problematisch und jetzt sagen
wir nur noch geimpft und genesen raus
wer soll das denn bitte in welcher art
und weise kontrollieren die frage wollen
wir in einer solchen republik leben wo
sie sich sozusagen hier impfausweis aufs
revers tucker müssen das sind ja das
funktioniert ja nicht deshalb glaube ich
und das ist auch der grund warum mir
gesagt haben es muss ein zeichen geben
wo diese beschränkung grundsätzlich für
alle fallen warum für alle weil die die
sich nicht impfen lassen wollen schaden
in erster linie sich selbst
und dann müssen sie eben schauen wie sie
wie sie damit umgehen können aber wir
werden doch nicht habe keine fantasie
wie man am ende einen teil helge braun
hat das ja auch noch vor wochen gesagt
kein lockdown mehr vergeben für mich
gibt's denn dann wer will denn das bitte
kontrollieren wie soll das funktionieren
also es ist ja richtig die tests sind
nicht so sicher keine frage da hat er
völlig recht und ich kann mir sehr gut
vorstellen dass es zum beispiel
kinobetreiber dieses mal auf bei mir
bitte nur geimpft habe ich kein theater
mit nachverfolgung ist es hier ruhig für
die gäste auch ein kriterium das kann
dass wir die privatparty fc köln zum
beispiel macht dass er sagt nur geimpfte
dürfen in stade
ja das ist ja das ist ja legitim
beschließen die an welchen instanzen und
c wie wollen sie es kontrollieren also
ich glaube das kann ist von der idee
vielleicht nachvollziehbar das wird ja
nicht funktionieren deshalb glaube ich
tatsächlich macht machen sinn zeitpunkt
wo man sagt impfangebot gibt es jetzt
für alle
wer nicht will der hat schon ab dann
auch bitte die tests kostenpflichtig mit
ausnahme der kinder die nicht kämpfen
können menschen die aus anderen gründen
nicht geben werden können dann kann man
auch eine härtefall klausel einbauen wie
wir das immer so schön machen
aber irgendwann muss doch mal gut sein
denn wir haben ganz viele und die
erwischen wir auch noch mit solchen
maßnahmen die im moment das extrem
bequem fanden sich werden sie abends
essen ein schnelltest an der ecke geholt
haben fürs impfen aber keine zeit keine
lust hatten und ich glaube das kann ich
auf dauer nicht aber wir werden
einfach und ich glaube das ist auch eine
entscheidung die wir gemeinschaftlich
treffen müssen das muss ab müssen
zeitpunkt gelten
wer sich bei einem allgemein verfügbaren
impfstoff nicht impfen ist der darf das
machen man darf unvernünftig sein das
ist erlaubt aber bitte dann sollten die
anderen nicht mehr dafür sozusagen in
verantwortung genommen werden für jemand
der aus weil er daran glaubt dass bill
gates in schritt 1 pflanze oder
sonstiger und trug sich nicht impfen
lassen will dann muss er eben sehen wir
selber klar kommt er oder sie und muss
eine maske tragen oder soll es bleiben
lassen und wird im extremfall krank das
ist aber glaube ich das machen wir bei
allen anderen erkrankungen ja auch bei
influenza wällen die wir jedes jahr
haben sagt man ja nicht plötzlich sind
die über 60 m potenziell gefährdet wir
wissen nicht die impfquoten da sind
gruselig bei prenzlau
deshalb sagen wir auch nicht alle keine
gemeinschaftlichen veranstaltungen keine
maske wir müssen bei corona sukzessive
zu einer gewissen normalität kommen und
die normalität kann jetzt langsam kommt
weil wir eben eine situation am dass das
gesundheitssystem mit diesen fällen die
die kommen werden und das werden auch
mehr werden alles andere ja
verwunderlich damit werden wir aber
fertig und vielleicht ist sogar ein
gewisses ansteigende zahlen durchaus
auch noch andere motivation schönen
anderen sich doch impfen zu lassen
nicht dass ich mir viele kranke wünsche
ganz im gegenteil aber wir sehen auch in
england mit zahlen die uns ja wirklich
hier von einer ohnmacht in die andere
verließen mit 30.000 neue infektionen am
tag oder die 20.000 weg eines
signifikanten steigerung der
krankenhauseinweisung sehen in keinerlei
verhältnis wie es früher war
die haben natürlich
krankenhauseinweisungen die haben auch
mehr als sie hatten bei einer inzidenz
von 2000 aber sie haben eben nicht
faktor 10 sondern sie haben sie in
serbien steigerungen und das werden wir
auch erleben wir werden mehr kranke
sehen wir werden auch wahrscheinlich ein
paar todesfälle mehr sehen aber das ist
irgendwann ein auch teil einer
normalität die so ein - was weltweit das
ist ja das einzigartige weltweit durch
nicht mehr existente grenzen für wir
nehmen sie flugzeug verkehr das zeug
verteilt sich in einem ganzen welt und
das ist überall und nach irgendwann wird
jeder weltbürger entweder gehabt haben
oder wird gegeben worden seien
herr blume ab wieviel toten pro tag oder
im monat bei corona sind sie bereit
wieder zu sagen na ja das ist jetzt
vergleichbar mit influenza mit anderen
krank
die wir auch in der vergangenheit bereit
waren zu akzeptieren und die kanzlerin
sagt bis zum 21 september hat jeder dann
am ende das angebot zu impfung bekommen
also angelegt an dem was er gestern
gesagt hat wann ist es dann die
eigenverantwortung des einzelnen und ab
wann werden dann die anderen die
vielleicht schon geimpft sind oder die
geimpft sind dann nicht mehr in
geiselhaft genommen
also ich finde es unethisch jetzt
menschen leben sozusagen gegeneinander
aufzurechnen eine solche nützlichkeit
ethik dies mir persönlich jedenfalls
völlig fremd klar ist aber natürlich
gibt es ein allgemeines lebensrisiko und
der staat kann nie und nimmer auf dauer
dieses allgemeine lebensrisiko für jeden
einzelnen komplett abnehmen und
insbesondere dann wenn jeder sein
persönliches impfangebot hatte dann
ändert sich natürlich etwas dann treten
wir ein in eine neue zeit da sind wir
uns ja alle einig aber umso wichtiger
ist es dann dass man eine anschluss
strategie hat und die anschluss
strategie als alternative zum komplett
lockdown eines landes kann er nur sein
dass man dann differenzierter vorgehen
und über dieses differenzierte vorgehen
muss jetzt beginnend mit der mpk
gesprochen werden
und ich bleibe bei meinen punkt ich sehe
schon starke gründe dafür dann zu
differenzieren zwischen menschen die
games genesen sind oder eben nur
getestet sind
und das argument dass man das ja nur
schwerlich kontrollieren könnte in
anderen ländern in der welt ist nach wie
vor restaurantbesuch zum beispiel in
österreich nur möglich für geimpfte
genesene oder dort noch eher getestet
das wird dort auch kontrolliert und ich
sehe keinen restaurantbetreiber da die
grenzen seiner möglichkeiten kommen wenn
wir über das sprechen was uns alle
bewegt nämlich die frage wie viele
menschen in deutschland geimpft sind
dann muss man sagen dass die
impfkampagne an fahrt verliert bei uns
liegen mit 54,5 prozent vollständig
geimpfter liegen wir hinter sieben
europäischen ländern darunter spanien
england und italien
meine frage was können wir tun frau
leutheusser schnarrenberger um da mehr
vaart rein zu bekommen und endlich auf
einen höheren prozentzahl zu kommen und
woran liegt es
also ich glaube ganz wichtig ist dass
sehr viel stärker gelten muss der
impfstoff muss zu den menschen kommen
und nicht installieren die die menschen
müssen in impfzentren und zu ärzten
gehen
das ist zwar alles richtig und gut
hausärzte ganz ganz wichtig die haben
dynamik reingebracht neben den
impfzentren aber wir sehen doch es muss
ganz kreative mobile angebote in
unterschiedlicher form
beim markt beim fußballstadion in
vereinen wo auch immer angebote geben
zum impfen und dann wird auch mehr
geimpft aber zu meinen die leute kommen
jetzt noch innen impfzentrum um sich
impfen zu lassen das nimmt wirklich ab
und führt auch zur vernichtung von
impfdosen und wenn das dazu führt dass
sich hier eine eiskugel kriege oder in
sachsen oder thüringen bratwurst und das
ist etwas wo die leute sagen mensch dann
gehe ich hin die nehme ich mit und lass
mich impfen ja sehr wohl ich bin nicht
dafür hier geld mit geld um einzuwerfen
das machen ja andere länder die den akku
und aber warum nicht aber spricht denn
dagegen zu sagen
er spricht denn dagegen mal am ende
schade dass ungeimpfte unserer
volkswirtschaft warum nehmen wir nicht
geld in die hand sagen begeben eine
prämie also wir können den anreize geben
in form von auch im einkaufs gutschein
wird auch teilweise gemacht kommt auch
an bei den leuten das finde ich richtig
die versicherungen in unterschiedlicher
art bieten ja auch anreize die dak und
andere
das ist gut aber es sollte nicht in
dimensionen gehen wie wir es in anderen
ländern haben wo man eine wohnung
kriecht im wert von 100.000 euro oder
sonst etwas aber solche anreize vor ort
mit den entsprechenden mobilen
kapazitäten ich glaube das kann uns noch
mal wirklich ein deutliches stück
voranbringen bei der impfquote mit all
den auswirkungen die wir diskutiert
haben nämlich dann nicht mehr mit
beschränkungen für die menschen
vergessen was wirklich gegen die
impfmüdigkeit der deutschen
na ja gut wenn wir das wüssten wir es ja
einfach dass das zu machen also ich
finde auch
unsere eben sport ist jetzt nicht so
schlecht also muss ich doch nicht so
schlecht denn wir haben das problem das
ist ja immer so wenn noch niemand geben
das dann können sie sehr schnell sehr
viele menschen im von die letzten meter
werden dann immer schwerer ein aspekt
ist sicherlich warum wir so ein bisschen
hinten dranhängen wir haben ja anfangs
bedingt durch die impfstoff nach weil da
eine sehr strikte priorisierung was
heißt gerade die jungen nicht geimpft
mit der aussage die unverändert gilt die
werden in der regel nicht schwer krank
und sterben auch nicht das stimmt die
haben also sehr lange auf impfung warten
müssen und stellen jetzt natürlich
ungefähr ist naja gut jetzt habe ich so
lang kann impfung gab offensichtlich
erkranken tue ich nicht muss nicht sein
im funk schenk ich mehr oder sind jetzt
im urlaub also da kann man sicherlich
ein bisschen nacharbeiten da werden wir
noch mehr an impfung bekommen und das
ist natürlich auch die gruppe der
menschen die weise eben jung und gesund
sind normalerweise nicht in arztpraxen
rumhängt von daher ist es sicher richtig
sich alternative impf angebote zu
überlegen
es ist auch sinnvoll in soziale
brennpunkte zu gehen das alles sind
dinge die kann man machen man kann das
bewerben hier sind auch sicherlich
testimony ist ganz ganz hilfreich ich
glaube auch dass wir durchaus noch bei
den impfungen zu legen aber ich glaube
man sollte sich davor hüten mit
impfquoten zu agieren und auch die zum
charakter hat wir bauen über über 80
prozent lag
das will man unter uns das werden wir
nicht erreichen warum nicht wir haben
alleine 9,2 millionen menschen unter
zwölf für die gibt's keinen impfstoff
jetzt können sie schon mal abziehen da
sind schon mehr als zehn prozent der
bevölkerung dann haben wir offiziell 4
millionen genesene die dunkelziffer wird
zwei bis vier fach so hoch sein also
wahrscheinlich auch noch mal fünf bis
zehn millionen menschen die krone hatten
wir haben eine harte impfverweigerer
quote die je nach umfrage irgendwo
zwischen 10 und 15 prozent nicht mehr
das addieren kann das schon nicht
funktionieren ich würde mir so gar nicht
den hals so eng machen zu wollen mit
denen sputen wenn wir eine impfquote
hinbekommen von 70 plus dann ist das das
reicht auch wir werden dann kaum
relevante erkrankungen sehen und da
sollte alles daransetzen diese importe
zu bekommen das schaffen wir auch mit
der erwachsenen wohnbevölkerung wenn es
dann 12 bis 17 uhr gibt die nach
abschnitt mit ihren eltern aus
verschiedensten gründen sagen ich möchte
mich impfen lassen wunderbar ist das
auch in ordnung da sollten uns hüten
alle miteinander implizit druck
aufzubauen
aber man kann durchaus bei der
erwachsenen wohnbevölkerung incentives
starten
und das können auch negative seite das
wort glaube ich da sind wir wieder beim
thema braucht und kann der staat kaum
umsetzen zu sagen du darfst du nicht ins
kino wenn die kino werden schon selber
sagen wir kommen wenn ich rein will
nicht geben habe kim mit lungen mit wie
viel prozent werden sie zufrieden die
kanzlerin hat meine herren die immunität
mal gesprochen von 82 83 glaube ich wie
viel brauchen wir da geimpfte ab wann
sagen sie okay das ist jetzt in ordnung
das ziel der hätten immunität ist hier
nach wie vor ein erstrebenswertes
alleine die latte wurde in den letzten
monaten dann anders gelegt weil die
wirksamkeit der impfstoffe sich
offensichtlich mit den neuen mutationen
verändert hat das heißt die latte ab der
erden um militär reicht wird liegt
inzwischen deutlich höher
inzwischen oder moment sind wir gar
nicht in der situation dass wir uns
jetzt mit der frage auseinandersetzen
können können wir da die 80 überspringen
sondern zwischen der doktor gassen
gesagt hatte ich wäre froh wenn wir es
schaffen in deutschland jetzt erst mal
die 70 irgendwie zu erreichen und dazu
ist alles notwendig was gesagt wurde
auch von frau leutheusser
schnarrenberger so niederschwellig wie
möglich so einfach wie möglich wird zu
starken anreizen wie irgend denkbar und
gerne auch mit negativen anreizen das
thema sollten wir nicht ausklammern
für diejenigen die sich der hartnäckig
weigern was machen sie dann werde ich
nie kapieren bereichen seien
naja also dass diejenigen die sich eben
verweigern dem impfen
und zwar nicht mit gründen weil es weil
sie halt aus gesundheitlichen gründen
nicht können sondern weil sie einfach
nicht wollen dass die dann einfach auch
sehen und wissen dass ihnen bestimmte
möglichkeiten dann halt eben nicht
gegeben sind welche möglichkeiten die
neuen und jugendlichen werden nicht
angegeben werden
blum ist glaube ich noch ein wichtiger
punkt was meinen sie damit also wenn man
diejenigen bestrafen will und über das
ich kann mir vorstellen dass es dann
situationen geben wird dass man sagt
großveranstaltungen restaurantbesuch
kino besucht die beispiele die gerade
aufgezählt wurden kann eine situation
eintreten dass dann das dass dann nur
für geimpfte oder genesende möglich sein
wird ich würde gern dem krieg noch mal
richten auf die kinder und jugendlichen
und zwar auf die alterskohorte für die
auch in impfstoff zugelassen ist es war
wahrscheinlich etwas misslich dass wir
eine relativ längliche diskussion hat
nun das keine ganz klare empfehlung gab
wiewohl der impfstoff für die über 12
jährigen dann auch zugelassen war
gerade mit blick auf einen sicheren
schulbetrieb und gerade mit blick auf
die tatsache dass natürlich an den
schulen immer auch ein gewisses
infektionsgeschehen weitergegeben wurde
man hat das ja auch in großbritannien
gesehen
die zahlen sind deutlich zurückgegangen
wie das freiheits tages wegen des
freedom day sondern weil die kinder die
ferien gegangen sind ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass wir in deutschland dann
auch über hornissen sind dass wir
nachher blume das werden sie entspricht
den standardwerten ja nicht wir sehen
immer noch dass die kurve weiter nach
unten geht also sie können bis heute
kann man nicht sagen dass es wieder nach
oben gegangen ist ich sage ja eben weil
ferienzeit ist und deswegen müssen wir
sicherstellen dass wenn die kinder auch
in deutschland jetzt wieder die schule
kommen dass erstens das was eine
infektionsgeschehen vielleicht auch aus
dem ausland nach deutschland hinein
getragen wurde da nicht zufällig wieder
schule breit macht ist jedoch wie sehen
wir noch mal die neue die große die
zahlen in den ersten schultagen sie
sehen die kurve geht weiter nach unten
in den letzten tagen in den letzten
wochen und das obwohl sie und andere
immer davor gewarnt haben das ist alles
unmöglich gewesen sein wie sozusagen
boris johnson dort verfährt das alles
völliger wahnsinn gewesen wäre und auch
die europameisterschaft und so viele
zuschauer und alle zusammen und alles
würde ganz schrecklich werden und diese
kurve beweist ja so ein bisschen das
gegenteil oder die zahlen haben sich
fast halbiert so beweist gar nichts
diese kurve beweis gar nicht sie sollten
zeigen dass ab dem freedom day die
zahlen nach unten gingen ich glaube wir
beide wissen herr uns aber dass es da
keinerlei korrelation miteinander gibt
entscheidend ist doch was aber es gibt
für ihre these vorher dass die zahlen
weiter durch die decke gehen würden
erstens durch den freedom day zweitens
durch die europameisterschaft und all
das was von stolz und gemacht hat davor
haben sie ja aus münchen immer wieder
massiv gewarnt das müssen sie doch mal
zu geben so viel ehrlichkeit gehört dazu
ich habe herr uns habe ich etwas ganz
anderes gesagt ich habe gesagt die
tatsache dass kinder in die
schulferien gegangen sind hat
möglicherweise wesentlich dazu fall
gebracht jetzt stellen sie in der
theorie auf die nächste war aber mir
geht es ja um die warnung und mahnung
die sie vorher angestellt haben herr
söder sie und andere in der union die
immer gesagt haben dass der boss
johnston dort macht es völliger wahnsinn
und die zahlen werden durch die decke
gehen und sie sind nicht durch die decke
gegangen
naja aber entschuldigung er uns einmal
vergleichen sie doch mal deutschland und
großbritannien unterliegen wie
offensichtlich lichtjahre auseinander
und das hat ja irgendwelche gründe
möchte ich aber im vierten anlauf mein
punkt gerne machen ich möchte hier
sicherlich antwort einfach nicht auf
meiner diese frage am apparat zu diesem
gesicherten schulstadt gehört dass wir
verlässlichkeit in den schulalltag
bringen dass wir die infektions dynamik
die vielleicht auch aus dem urlaub mit
ins land getragen wurde dass wir die
brechen deswegen gibt es gute gründe zu
sagen schulstart an zunächst mal mit
maske und gesunde kinder wieder streute
lange mit maximo lider sich sitzen
das dass wir kinder und jugendliche dann
auch mit einem intel ins angebot
und da hat man den punkt mehr zu bleiben
sie bei dem punkt müssen sich aber
bleiben wir dran das ist richtig wollen
formuliert das ist sehr wichtig weil das
viele eltern angeht und wieder auch sehr
sehr viele reaktionen bekommen habe eben
von eltern die das kaum noch ertragen
konnten wie viele stunden ihre kinder
dort mit maske sitzen müssen nur weil
die politik die regierung ist nicht
geschafft hat zum beispiel luftfilter
anzubringen
einfach eine eine situation zu schaffen
die ohne maske möglich ist vergessen
wie nehmen sie das wahr dass der blume
wird sagt im neuen schuljahr kinder
müssen da wieder mit maske sitzen
na gut das ist die maske diskussion dass
sie die eine das problem was man
vielleicht noch mal deutlich heraus aber
das interessiert mich sind sie da der
meinung dass es richtig ist müssen die
schulkinder dort mit maske wieder sitzen
also ich glaube wenn man konsequent das
was man seit einem jahr ist nämlich dass
man vernünftige lüftungsanlagen schon
installieren kann
macht hätte können wäre das sicherlich
verzichtbar ist das muss ich gestehen
viel empfinde ich persönlich als bürger
als staatsversagen dass man das nicht
hingekriegt hat das problem der impfung
für die schüler das ist ja nur die halbe
wahrheit denn ich habe vorhin gesagt
unter zwölf gibt es keinen stress in
neun millionen kinder
das ist also der großteil derjenigen die
zwölf- bis 17-jährigen sind ja zum teil
schon genehmigt und sind jetzt auch
nicht die treiber der infektion
was aber die ganze diskussion vor
handwäsche gezeigt hat freedom day ist
sicherlich nicht der grund warum die
zahlen gesunken ist aber nicht der grund
warum sie ansteigen und ähnlich hatte
sich auch mit den lottozahlen sie können
eine beliebige grafen anlegen das ist
doch dieses thema der kontrolle illusion
was england einfach zeit ist dass die wo
impfquote bei schweren verläufen schützt
weil doch sehr hohen infektionszahlen
dabei aber ich möchte noch bereit um
schulen bleiben es ist mir sehr wichtig
weil das eben viele menschen angeht also
wie geht jetzt dieses schuljahr wenn
alle wieder in der schule sind wie kann
es weitergehen
machen sie sich sorgen dass am ende aus
der politik weil eben luftfilter nicht
angebracht wurden weil er dort nichts
passiert ist am ende die kinder in
wieder locker umgehen könnten
also ich mache mir keine sorgen ich bin
mir relativ sicher dass du genau das
passieren wird wir werden wieder wechsel
unterricht erleben die kinder werden den
masken sitzen und das ist das für mich
auch kaum erträgliche szenarien heilfroh
dass meine kinder aus der schule raus
sind
da ist aus meiner sicht viel zu wenig
gemacht haben und das ist das was ich
auch kritisch findet dass man jetzt
durch diese versäumnisse im grundsatz
durch einen impf angebot für nur einen
kleinen teil der schulpflichtigen kinder
versucht so ein bisschen weg zwischen
sagen wenn wir die jetzt alle 12 bis 17
ist es nicht so schön dass wir keine
lüftungsgeräte eingebaut haben das ist
so ein bisschen zwei unterschiedliche
dinge wir hätten das lange machen müssen
und das hätte eigentlich im letzten
sommer schon beginnen müssen im sommer
20 nicht im herbst 21 uhr überraschen
die kinder wieder aus den ferien kommen
und das impfen ist eine ganz andere
thematik die parallel dazu läuft aber
das impfen jetzt zum sine qua non für
einen geordneten schulbetrieb zu machen
ist aber inhaltlich nicht richtig das
muss man einfach sagen und es würde auch
nicht funktionieren weil wir mehr als
die hälfte der schriftliche gehen ja gar
nicht impfen können weil das weltweit
keinen impfstoff für sie gibt der
zugelassen ist und noch mal das impfen
der 12 bis 17 jährigen
das cdc die usa haben eine relativ klare
neben wirkungskette von rund 1 zu 18.000
mit mikrokrediten also
herzmuskelentzündung festgestellt
die glücklicherweise meistens nicht
immer ausfallen
und jetzt stellt sich die frage ist ein
12 bis 17 jahren mehr durch corona
gefährdet als durch die impfung und
genau das ist der grund warum die stiko
gesagt das kann man fast nicht
entscheiden und aus diesem grund geben
wir keine allgemeine impfempfehlung das
ist die frage wie sie ist deshalb kann
man es trotzdem machen und es ist auch
trotzdem eine im regelfall sichere
impfung
ich glaube nur das ist ein ganz
schwieriges ding das mit dem
schulbetrieb zu verknüpfen
man muss es von der individuellen schutz
situation für die jugendlichen sehen und
nicht das ist bequem weil wir dann
einfacher den schulbetrieb wieder auf
das alles nicht verknüpft werden
machen sie so viel im druck weil sie da
beim schutz der schulen beim schutz der
schülerinnen und schüler so versagt
haben nein ich würde sagen das eine tun
und das andere nicht lassen
das impfen ist ganz wichtig so wie es
der sackgassen gerade ausgeführt hat in
den ersten schultagen in den ersten 23
schulwochen wird uns die maske helfen
manche seien unentdeckter infektionen
dir eingetragen wird in den schulbetrieb
vielleicht auch zu unterbinden an
weiterer infektionen und darüber hinaus
wird natürlich der einsatz von
luftfiltern auch ein ganz entscheidender
baustein sein
ich weiß aus ganz vielen gesprächen
werden der sehr energische diskussionen
die kommunen ächzen oder dieser aufgabe
am ende haben sie aber verstanden dass
gerade auch von der elternschaft
erwartet wird dass der staat wirklich
alles tut einen gesicherten schulbetrieb
zu gewährleisten deswegen ist auch
dieses lüfter thema so entscheiden das
ist nicht eine maßnahme sondern ich
glaube die kombination anderthalb jahre
schon in überherrn für den gesicherten
schulbetrieb leute gegangen aber von den
drei dingen von den drei dingen die ich
genannt habe war am anfang nur eine
maßnahme zur verfügung bestand nämlich
die maske und jetzt zum glück haben wir
noch zwei weitere frau leutheusser
schnarrenberger wie sehen sie die
schulsituation also der luftfilter ist
eine debatte seit monaten ich bin ja
auch kommunalpolitisch aktiv alle
gemeinderäte befassen sich damit und
natürlich hätte es viel früher auch die
finanziellen
angebote gebrauch zur unterstützung weil
natürlich die sachaufwandsträger kommune
stadt oder kreis gerade jetzt nach
corona kaum in der lage sind alle
luftfilter zu bezahlen dass das nicht
besser organisiert angeboten und
durchgeführt wurde
das ist wirklich ein staatsversagen und
das ist unverzichtbar
mit maske jetzt wieder schülerinnen und
schüler zum schul gewinn zum schulbeginn
also zu verpflichten das halte ich für
wirklich problematisch dass über man
dann wieder maske auch nur im unterricht
mehr absetzen darf in dem moment wo man
aufsteht aufsetzen muss maske ist nicht
so eingriffs intensiv wie manch anderes
aber für schülerinnen und schüler im
schulbetrieb ist es so eine massive
beschränkung als ich denke da muss man
alles tun dass man davon weg kommt also
die schulen brauchen wörtlich seinen
freedom day das wieder richtiger
unterricht geht mit den
rahmenbedingungen mit dem filter und
aufs impfen kann man nicht setzen das
ist der teil die von herrn cassens
einschätzung risiko und nutzen abwägung
ist eben noch nicht so daten basiert
dass man da eine allgemeine empfehlung
geben kann aber natürlich die eltern das
für sich entscheiden können aber das
wird nicht die quote sein um zu sagen
damit kriegen wir den schulbetrieb hin
und deshalb ist es wirklich also am
übermorgen muss dann noch mal einen
schub kommt von den ministerpräsidenten
dass das wirklich auch in nrw wenn in 14
tagen die schule wieder losgeht in
bayern ist ja noch zeit bis september
das dann klar ist die rahmenbedingungen
sind da dass es keinen dissens
unterricht mehr gibt sondern
präsenzunterricht ich spanne debatte hat
glaube ich gezeigt wie wichtig die
nächsten tage den nächsten wochen werden
zum abschluss meine frage angebunden an
das was ich am anfang gefragt habe herr
gassen kurz beantwortet für welchen
monat erwarten sie das alles fällt das
alles wieder normal wird hier in
deutschland in europa also ich glaube es
wäre vertreter tatsächlich ist eines im
fanggebiet zu koppeln und von daher ist
könnte man sicherlich ab
september/oktober den bürgern sagen ab
jetzt ist es individuell verantwortung
welche maßnahmen wir für euch als
notwendig erachtet und welche maßnahmen
wir dann auch anwendet ich würde mir
sehr viel mehr freiheit für den
einzelnen wünschen aber das impfangebot
sollte stehen das ist bis ende september
spätestens oktober erfolgt also freedom
day aus ihrer sicht ende september herr
blume wie sehen sie sie wollen am anfang
ein konkretes datum sehen aber
vielleicht wurden sie von den klugen
argumenten von herrn gassen überzeugt
jetzt doch ein datum zu nennen
ich habe nur der sendung wahrgenommen
dass eigentlich jeder schwierigkeit man
hat ein konkretes datum zu nennen und
ich kann das auch absolut nachvollziehen
und ich halte es auch weiterhin so
kroner bekämpfung ist nicht
lotteriespiel sondern heißt aber nun ja
nun würde reichen sowie kerzen gesagt
also ende september oktober
ich halte ich sehe mich auch außerstande
einen monat zu nennen wir haben eine tag
der deutschen einheit das ist der
deutsche freiheitstag aber was die
korona bekämpfung angeht wird die
geschichte von dem corona virus leider
auf andere art geschrieben
vor lauter schnarrenberger freedom day
am tag der deutschen einheit
zumindest eine idee von herrn summe also
ich würde das jetzt nicht unbedingt mit
dem tag der deutschen einheit verbinden
das ist ein freuden und freiheitstag
immer egal wie eine pandemie auch
irgendwo stattfindet aber politik muss
sich doch ehrgeizige ziele setzen und
deshalb bin ich bayern passen ja mitten
im angebot für alle und das ist jetzt ja
schon dabei ist bahn hat gesagt es gibt
ja jetzt schon mal ein angebot für alle
also dass wir spätestens im mitte
september und ende september der fall ja
und dann ging ich für ein freedom day da
bin ich bei herrn kassen
herzlichen dank für die spannende
diskussionen herzlichen dank markus
blume csu generalsekretär herzlichen
dank herr gassen chef der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung und
herzlichen dank der ehemaligen
justizministerin sabine
leutheusser-schnarrenberger und ich
wünsche ihnen allen und ich wünsche uns
vor allem dass da in der nächsten woche
nichts blüht auf das wir nicht
vorbereitet sind und wir endlich ein
datum bekommen wann die freiheit wieder
da ist alles erfahren sie natürlich hier
bei bild
morgen gibt es eine live sendung und wir
sind bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz in alter
tradition wieder dabei und auch ich bin
dabei ich freue mich herzlichen dank und
einen schönen guten ab
[Musik]